meet John a talented programmer who is
looking to start a company that used his
personally developed mobile application
to connect restaurants and customers for
booking and reservations
even though the app was ready John had
difficulty getting together a team for
his startup needing separate people for
sales marketing programming content
creation and customer support
hiring reliable Manpower while being
strict with his budget was getting
difficult
he reached out to his friend Ryan who
said John could start his company
without hiring any new people thanks to
just a single AI based tool John
couldn't believe it which led Ryan to
introduce chat gbt the Revolutionary AI
chatbot being developed by openai it is
a state-of-the-art natural language
processing or NLP model that uses a
neural network architecture to provide
responses
this means that the chat GPT bot can
answer questions without being
explicitly told what the answer is using
its own intellect unlike previous AI
chat Bots
so how does chat GPT help John in
filling out his team
regarding sales chatgpt can provide
full-fledged sales pitches based on the
correct prompts it can provide tips on
how to pitch your product businesses
removing the need for sales training
completely customized to your
requirements and your prompts if you
don't like some things about the
response you can ask for certain changes
and the chat bot will make sure they are
done when it comes to marketing chatgpt
can provide efficient marketing
strategies which can help new
entrepreneurs learn how to Market their
products to prospective clients it can
provide trending keywords that marketers
can use for SEO purposes while providing
ad copies for your website and blog
speaking of websites since John can do a
lot of the heavy lifting and programming
chat GPT can help proofread the code and
help out when looking for bugs to fix
apart from basic bug fixing it can also
provide sample code structures for
different programming languages allowing
John to focus more on improving core
functionality and workflow rather than
fixing basic code errors
websites and blogs content is very
helpful in gathering potential customer
leads
the Revolutionary bot can provide
full-length blog posts with near perfect
fast accuracy in seconds allowing
further customization like choosing the
length of the subject matter to the
complexity of language
for John's customer support the bot can
draft complete customer service emails
based on the situation saving time and
resources
the tone of the message can be changed
to reflect the nature of the message
creating an efficient alternative for
call centers professionals
John was left speechless seeing this
level of Versatility from chat GPT and
wanted to implement it right away
however Ryan made sure John knew about
some drawbacks of the chat bot before
getting started
since the bot is trained mostly on data
up to 2021 many of the newer events May
still need to be discovered by chat GPT
even basic stuff like asking about the
current date and time is beyond its
scope much like the limited
understanding of context despite
providing near-lifelike solutions to
certain problems even the accuracy of
many responses can be questioned since
the AI model is still learning and being
developed there is a section of the
public that believes the Revolutionary
tool can one day replace Google search
but that day seems far-fetched so far
because of the variety of issues people
keep running into and using chat GPT so
here's a question for you which of the
following tasks cannot be carried out by
chat GPT
one provide latest news 2. complex
mathematical calculations
three food recipes four none of the
above
however chat GPT poses a lot of promise
for the future of AI from full-skilled
automated divisions and organizations to
serving as the perfect digital assistant
open AI is creating a bot for the future
aimed at solving the problems of today
with the tools of Tomorrow the ability
to carry out a myriad of tasks with
minimum Manpower will boost productivity
at organizations in every sector thanks
to the Revolutionary chat GPT
so how do you think chat GPT will
benefit your daily life are you looking
forward to using the bot regularly for
work or personal life let us know your
thoughts in the comments below now let's
understand how Jazz gbt actually works
this model is pre-trained on the last
text data set and then fine tune on a
smaller data set specific to the
everyday task when the model receives
input from a user it uses the pattern it
learned during fine tuning to generate a
response let's take another example the
model can generate an appropriate
response even if the input is not a
complete question or a sentence after
seeing what is chargeability and how it
works now moving forward let's see how
we can use shared GPT in our day-to-day
life
so this is the Google search here we
will write
chat dot open AI
dot com slash chat
it will take time
so this is the chat window UI
objectivity
so our first use case is chargpt can
explain complex subjects okay so first
we will ask like what
is
neuroscience
it will take time
it's taking time to load because many of
the users are using
it started Neuroscience is the
scientific study of the nervous system
which includes the brain it will write
all about the Neuroscience you can ask
anything any subject okay like Heart to
Heart easy any or even you can stop
generating two if you want to
okay
so this is how you can ask like any
question to the any complex question to
charge gbt okay
we'll ask one more like what
is
quantum
it's loading
I don't know why it's taking time
because of net issue or I don't know why
take time and it will come
Quantum compute is the field of computer
science that uses properties of quantum
mechanics to perform operations on data
like this okay
two states zero or one and all the
content
Computing knowledge
okay
so this is how you can ask anything like
any about any complex subject to the
charge ability okay
so we chat our Second Use cases we can
write code using chat GPT okay we can
write so here I will give give me
a machine
learning
right
program
what
prediction
okay press enter
okay so here it's starting there is a
simple Python program that uses cited
Line library there's this and this
this is how you can take write a code
any code if you ask anything like
sorting like add two numbers I've uh
palindrome
anything you can anything you can ask
from chargeability it will give you a
code proper code
please note that this is a simple
example of sort prediction is a complex
task and this example is not enough to
make a good prediction it would need a
lot more data feature engineering and
model tuning to make accurate prediction
Okay so
let me give another Java
implementations implementation
of the what bubble
algorithm okay
let me ask this
yeah it started like here is a Java
implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm
so if you proper runnable algorithm
okay like bubble sort
of give you full
you can ask any type of code any type of
like apis anything
it will explain to this implementation
using nested Loop to compare adjacent
element in the area and swipe them if
they are in the wrong order
okay
and then after the outer loop completes
the array will be sorted in ascending
order our third use case is we can debug
the code okay so for that
but I will I will take this one code
okay
I will take this code
and
here I will write debug the code and I
will paste it here
and what I will do I will instead of
temp
here
I will like I will write
okay I will add 2p okay so now
what it will do charge but you will do
it will debug see the error in the code
is in the this line
okay
TMP it should be temp
you can see here
it is stamp
so from jativity you can debug the error
okay you can have the conversation with
to pull the charity like if you have any
question you can directly write what's
wrong in the other question and like
this okay like you have an extra p in
this variable name which is causing a
compile error this is because temp is
the variable that you declared earlier
to store the value of current element
where a stamp is not a variable that has
been declared so here you can see
the stamp is declared here
so that is that the error is causing the
code not to run once you fix the issue
okay like
sort the arrange ascending order using
the bubble total group okay so using
chat GPT you can easily debug your
errors the code and it is very helpful
on your project building okay so food
use case is you can create custom
marketing plans or strategy okay I'm
repeating again you can create custom
marketing plans or strategy like how so
here I will write how
could
remote
videos
on
social
media
present
it will give you proper plan how you can
promote your YouTube videos on your
social media
okay
I will chat with this okay I will ask
some question
views engagement everyone knows there
are a few strategies you can use C per
second and more like more to come like
share your video on personal social
media accounts just include your
Facebook Twitter Instagram and other
accounts thing like that join relevant
communities and groups grow use social
media ads platform like Facebook and
stuff
Instagram and Twitter
collaborate with influencer it is also
true create a hashtag for your videos
use YouTube video built-in sharing
features
it will give you all the marketing plans
it can create marketing plans any type
of plans
see remember your video should be
engaging information and should we
provide value to our audience
it is something like that now I will ask
one question to chat gbt
Okay so
I will ask what
if
make
only
travel videos
okay
what if I will make only okay
travel videos
so how
should
I
capture the
audience
you can ask any type of question okay
relevant to
this question or this answer you got
okay now let's see
it will give you everything if you are
making travel videos there are like few
strategies you can use to capture and
engage your audience
like this okay so the unique interesting
aspect of the destination you visit
people are often drawn to new and unique
experience like say share your personal
experience and insights it will give you
a proper plan
like how you can increase your audience
engage your audience okay
collaborate other travel bloggers it's
true engage with Audience by responding
to comments messages through
remember your video should be visually
appealing and provide valuable
information to your audience it is also
important to be authentic and true to
yourself like this okay so this is how
you can like using charge video how you
can create your marketing plans or your
something like that okay so our fifth
use cases we can generate articles and
blogs using charity okay so let me ask
right and
article
Sheen
learning
because agility is also machine learning
kind of machine learning on machine
learning
and
500 Words
presenter
it will write only exactly like 500
Words it will give you only 500 words
like machine learning is rapidly growing
field that is transforming the way we
live and work it is the branch of
artificial intelligence blah blah
yeah
basic idea of machine learning is that
computers can learn from data without
being explicitly programmed
like supervised learning is the most
common type of the machine learning just
through
yeah you can see here there are three
main types of machine learning
supervised learning and supervisor and
reinforcement
it's true
it will tell about like it will write a
proper
article in only 500 word not more than
that
machine learning has a potential
application Healthcare machine learning
patient data and more accurate diagnosis
like that
I wrote 500 Words
it will give you exactly 500
right you conclusion conversion machine
learning is rapidly growing field that
has the position to the rationalize many
Industries it allows computers to learn
from the data without being excretely
programmed
this is 500 Words of article
okay you can ask write article videos
descriptions blogs any kind of content
writing you can see
Okay so let's do one more question in
the same so I will give me
money
on
to write
okay skip for my YouTube
with Canon
YouTube channel YouTube shorts
videos
on Cyber
security
okay
here is a short skip for funny YouTube
video on cyber security
like narrator
where every clip could be your last
exactly
so something like that
so I always use strong password like
password One Two Three or quality
tip number two never click on suspicious
link unless it's linked to be to repeat
the
see this is how you can create your
funny
how you can generate your content from
chargeability using charging okay
thanks for watching stay safe out there
please note that that's scripted just
for fun exactly we know and not mean to
be taken seriously it's important to
take cyber security seriously and follow
best practices to protect your person
and professional data
okay
so this is how you can write
your make your content so easily like by
writing the title of the content so our
six use cases you can even Summarize the
book or article using charity PPT like
how I will write here summarize
a book
delivers travel
you just
no word written by Jonathan Swift in
this the book does the story of female
Gulliver a ship surgeon who become
Shipwrecked it will light only it will
summarize all about Gulliver travel yeah
in part one this happened
Oliver washes up on the island of
lilliputia exactly
would this happen and part three
discipline
because this is how you can summarize
any book any related to like educational
novel fiction any type of book or
article and blogs
okay whatever you want to summarize
okay it will run the book is being
commented on the Society of ship to one
time
okay so this is how you can Summarize
the book bully master
our seventh use cases we can ask
interview question two using charity so
here I can ask how to answer
interviewer
what
is
your
weakness
okay
so when answering the question it is the
best to be honest but also to frame your
answer in a positive way yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
I have a tendency to be perfectionate
and sometimes struggle with delegating
talk however I have been working on this
learning like this you can ask any
question any interview type question
okay related to HR or technical anything
you can ask
so let's see
how
to
answer
the
web viewer
like where do you see yourself
in next
five years
take
when answering this question it's good
idea to be aligned your answer with the
company's course and values yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
in five years I can see myself going
within the company and taking more
responsibility exactly
so this is how
you can ask any type of HR questions
you are facing off okay
so our next
use cases
our eighth use cases we can develop apps
using charge gbt
okay yes we can develop apps using
charitability like
I want
to write
and Android
app that
shows me
please talk
prices
as a
list
of
let's see Yahoo
API
okay
or how
can
I do
wait
like this so it will write a proper
Android app code for you
foreign
project or it will give you a proper
idea how you can make a you know app
all these steps
from starting to the last
choose a view holder to hold the
reference of the views for each item in
the list
okay
use asynchronous stars to fetch all this
stuff from starting to the end
this is a brief overview of the steps
and you will need to take a build
Android app
okay
okay so this is how you can like ask
anything to create
a
okay using any language flat uh Java
python any language okay I repeat our
ninth use cases we can create our
exercise plan diet plan using chargpt
okay so I would like my weight is 25
okay let's take
25 kg
and I want to
lose
create
seven days
period seven days
plan for
the advice
I plan for it
okay
it will create see here is a day
exercise and the diet plan that can help
you day one exercise 30 minute risk walk
or joke right start your day with
healthy breakfast of oatmeal berries
like this it will create exactly seven
days
okay so this is our ninth use case we
can make any type of plant diet plan
food plan exercise plan or anything
like marketing strategy
anything you want
timetable
of focusing something anything you can
make
and according to you yourself you can
rearrange them okay it will be very easy
and it is very time saving
okay it will create seven days plan
there's X exercise training session like
this right
is you want to lose
avocado toast with post deck
it's important to note that this is just
a planned Simple Plan
so our tense use cases last use case you
can ask any General Knowledge Questions
to charge
like
okay who invented
first
okay
you can cross question to charge pretty
answer okay
this is the all the use case of
charitability like
it can or debug the code audit the code
like explain complex subject create
custom marketing plan or strategy diet
plan exercise plan you can generate your
content like article blogs you can
Summarize the book and the Articles or
interview question preparation or
developing apps coding
you can easily do with the chat GPD and
it's been going all the developers
around the globe
so now we will start with automating
Excel with the help of chat jbt and with
the help of Python language
so first
we will create a folder and see the
Excel files
with which
we will use Python and with the help of
chat GPT
we will automate them
so first we'll create a folder for a
project and we will create in Python
projects and name it as
automate Excel using
chatgpt
and inside this
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open any idea link so that
we will write a request to chat GPT and
he'll answer us with the suitable code
and that code will copy paste into our
ideally and run it if it gives any error
we will copy paste the error same to the
chat GPT and as I know he answers them
so here
we will open our ideally and for that we
are writing a command that is code space
period and that will open our ideally
that is Visual Studio mode
now
we have opener ideally and first we'll
create a file here
or first we will see our Excel files on
which we will
do the automation
and for that
it'll get back to our folder
and here we have the number folder in
which we have two files that is CSV
files
phone number and phone number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the date of the sales of
the Year 2022
so we will use these files
sales and the number
so we'll cut them and
get to a folder
and inside the number file no we'll
start with sales
first we'll do the automation
with the sales files
so we'll open the sales folder
and inside that we will create a file
that would be the py file
and the first automation we would be
doing is concatenating all the files in
a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we will concatenate them
and ask the chat GPT to write the code
sorry to concatenate all these
so for that
we'll name the file as concatenate only
need
underscore data Dot py
so now
we will give the command to the chat GPT
so here is our child GPD and here
we will write a command for it
that would be I have 12 Excel files
and I want to concatenate them
and we'll also mention the name named
January
is this only
but we'll check with the final January
and then we have February
and moving on
so on we have till December
so we have all these 12 files and now
we'll command him
to use python
to concatenate the data inside the 12
axis files into one file
so this is a command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter
okay it shows us that an error occurred
if the issue is
so for this thing we will just copy the
open a link and paste it here and open
it
as the chair GPT is seeing a huge
traffic
sometimes it shows
these errors
so he is very famous but we are a robot
or not
so
we will agree with the chargpt
and answer its questions here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the charge ability and we'll paste
our Command here and press enter
and here you can see that it has started
answering our question that you can use
the pandas library in Python to read in
the data from each of the Excel files
and use the concat function to combine
the data from all the valves into one
data frame here's an example of how we
want to use okay
it's going in a very right menu
and he has imported pandas and then
create a data frame and
using the for Loop
is going to all the months reading the
Excel file
and appending okay done
and result he is concatenating but he
has not created the
Excel file where we can see all the data
and he has also not printed it so what
we want
so first we'll see
what does this code do as I have seen so
it will concatenate but it has not
created the Excel file in which we can
see all the data
so we have copied the code we will paste
it here
save it and run it
and most important thing you have to
import the pandas Library
and if you have not installed it please
install it in the command prompt with
the command pip install pandas or you
can use it in the terminal
okay
it has not found
the january.xls
okay so j n u a r y
okay it's spelling we will see
what error it expects
we'll save this and run once again
so we'll just copy the error and write
it back to chat GPT and see
how does it respond
okay is seeing is indicating that the
panel server is unable to find the Excel
file you are trying to read it based on
the error message look like the files
are not located in the same directory as
the python script
okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the library
in the same
folder
yeah
concatenate dot UI and we'll check once
again here
let's go data dot py yeah
they are in the same folder and why we
have this error
okay into
soon there it is we have opened our
ideally
in
the automated Excel using chat GPD
folder and currently we are in sales
folder
so it is not recognizing
the directory
so what we'll do
we'll copy all these files
copy the sales files
and paste it here
now
we'll run the port that
chat Jeopardy provided us
okay uh yeah it has done successfully
is good successfully okay we'll try once
again we'll kill the terminal
save it and run it again
now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
note
converted it into
a single Excel file for that we will
write
you forgot
to
create
the concatenated
file
as we also haven't mentioned in our
Command
specifically
so we have to be specific with our
commands also
let's see
yeah after creating the data frame
to export to a Excel file and we can
just write this command
and index equal to false here okay and
he's giving all the explanations so you
can just read them your correct I
apologize for the outside to create a
new Excel file light contains a
continued data you can use the to
understand method of the data frame here
is an example of how you could do this
okay you've got a new Excel file name
underscore data.xl SX the same directory
as your python script and it will
contain the concatenated data form
from all of the original Excel file you
could also use a to underscore CSU
method to save the data frame in CSV
format yeah
we can do that also
okay we'll
make the xlsx file
and just beneath it
okay uh
yeah
understand
okay
we don't need any path we'll just do it
here only
here result.2 Excel
and then let's go data dot excels
so we'll save this and run it
is showing that it has executed
successfully
and yeah outside the seeds folder we'll
close it you can see that it has created
the concatenated underscore data.xlsx
so for that remove area it has created
it here
we'll open it
and first I will show you
what these files contain
so every file have the entry of around
1000.
every file has thousand
entries
so the account created file should have
around 12000.
so this is the concentrated underscore
data
and if we go beneath
yeah we can see
and it's 12 yeah it says it has
concatenated all the data
responded and we have to precise with
the commands what we are writing in
English
as it has not mentioned to convert it
into Excel file now when we have written
it again it has done that
now moving on we will do the second
automation
and for that we'll move back to our
ideally and the next automation we would
be doing would be
that we will be using the sum and the
average function
to all the files that is from January to
December files and will
use sum and average function I will show
you we will use
so it's concatenated data
so we'll open the August file
and here
you can see the
quantity in the H column
so we'll average down the quantity
so what is the average per customer
and
in the J column we have the total cost
so we'll add all the cost in all the
files
this is the August file from January to
December we will do in color match
the average for the quantities and
column J will do the sum of the total
amount per customer
and we'll get it printed at the last
column
that would be we have the Thousand
entries
it's going till
h1001 so we would get it printed on
h1002 and the sum would get it printed
on j1002
okay so moving on we'll close these
files
we will get back to a charge upd and
give him a command that
I have 12 Excel files
and we'll tell him that we have named
them
January
then we have
February
then
we have till December
and now
we want you to use python
to
apply
the sum formula
the sum formula and the average formula
so the sum formula would be applied from
J2 to j1001
let's see okay we have closed file you
have what I remember
some formula
from
J2 to J one double zero one
okay and
the average function
and now we want him to use the average
formula
from H2 to h1001
okay and that would be in all the Excel
files
and we want him to write the results
in the cells and that would be J one
double zero two
and
h1002 is respectively
so we have to be precise with the
commands and we have
an error here and that is done and yeah
it's all done
I'll just
give this command to chat jpt and see
how it answers use the panel library in
Python to renew okay and perform the sum
and average calculations good and then
write the results back to the same file
here is an example of how you could do
this
yeah we are writing in the same file
okay very important is PD and running a
loop for all the months
we have red
all the Excel files one by one and
we are taking the cell
and I location okay and doing the sum
and doing the mean
of the H column yeah it's good
Excel
yeah
I think it would
do a job
so we'll copy this and create a new file
and name it as
sum Dot py
and inside this we will paste the code
that our GPT has provided us
and we'll run this
and it has executed successfully okay no
uh we got an error that is
okay okay
it has made the mistake
and rooted
okay
let me just see what query
I have 12xl files named January 2 the
summer news python to apply the sum
formula from J2 to
j1001 and average formula from H2 to
h1001 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done
uh we would be a little specific
this
cells j102
and okay
okay okay yeah
we'll once again submit it if we didn't
get
okay yeah now he has used open
y Excel Library that's all
yeah
that would be working first
let's see
what he will provide to us
okay
oh she active and
yeah
I think
you can solve the purpose but first
we'll run it
so he is
giving us the explanation for what he
has written this code that is this code
will apply the sum formula to the range
j22 j1001 and the average formula to the
range H2 to h1001 in all the Excel files
the results will be written in j1002 and
h1002 respectively it is important to
note that this code will overwrite the
original file so that it's recommended
to make a backup okay we don't need that
and we have backup in the sales folder
also so you can also the read underscore
excellent to underscore Excel function
from pattern
okay
so we'll try this code
uh it is
import OS and guys uh you have to
install all these libraries open py
Excel I have already installed them you
can search on the browser that open py
Excel installation Python and it would
be directed to pypi.com that's the
official website for the particular
libraries and there you can see the
command that will be the PIP install and
the particular command for the module
name
it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see
if it has done its job or not
and in the April file we have in the
edge column that is the average of the
edge column that puts the items and in
the J column we have the total sum of
the amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully chat GPT
has provided us with the perfect code
hats off to the Jet gbt and moving on
now we'll do some other automations
and now
what we can do
uh
we have other files that is phone number
and phone number two
and what it contains
it contains the phone numbers
so what we could do is
we could add the plus 91 extension that
is the country code for India
we will ask chatgpt to add the country
code plus 91 to both the files
so I'll close these files
and first
we'll copy them and paste in our
root directory so we don't get any error
and we'll
change the slide
name
instead of iPhone
and underscore
okay
now
we'll move back to charge upd and write
a command
and these files are CSV files node xlsx
file
yeah these are CSV files both the file
search files other files are xlsx files
okay so for that we will write the
command to charge DVD that
I have two files
uh
with DOT CSV extension
and they are named
phone underscore
number and the second was named
phone underscore number underscore two
okay so we have told the jet GPT that we
have two files and now we will tell him
to use python
to add the country code
and the
country
code
plus nine one
as
string prefix
and that would be adding as a string
prefix else it would only show nine one
it won't show plus so we'll see if chat
GPT understand that or not
as string prefix in both the CSV files
with
column name that was phone
okay now we'll just press enter
and wait for a charge APD to answer this
query
and we'll see
how it responds
you can use the printers as well okay
and that flips to the phone numbers and
the modified data packages are okay
[Music]
um
it's heading as step string okay it has
understood that
and to CSV
and this code will hit in both the files
here I think this will work
we have copied account it's controlled
in both CSV files and the plus timeline
string to the phone numbers and
write the modify data background says
files it's modern to know that this will
or write the original file so it's
required to make a backup with Originals
okay
I could also use the apply function to
add the prefix to the phone number in
the column okay
okay we can do this also
with the Lambda function
and that's what
this will also do a job
first we'll see this
and we will
create a file
for this Automation and name it as
country code dot py okay
and we'll
paste the code here
and run it for you guys
but showing that it has executed
successfully
uh yeah it has executed successfully
so we'll just
go back to our files
and see
whether the code plus 91 as in prefix or
not okay the numbers
okay the files code only nine one as
the column it's still in the number
format
it hasn't
converted into string format uh we'll
see the second code also
like
yeah it has converted x windows ring
okay Lambda X we'll see
whether it's working or not
it has worked uh and the issue is we
have
change the files permission denied okay
we have opened a file we'll close it
and Save
this and run it again
now it shows it has
executed successfully
we'll open the files
and now if we see
it is showing here now it has added two
nine months
yeah
uh so no issues uh the thing is first we
have to
transform it into the string format and
then we can add plus nine one as a
string to that string
so chat Jeopardy misses with the
slightest
implementation the code
now moving on uh we'll see this command
later
if you want to see how we can add Plus
90 I will tell you how to write that
code
okay
so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that chat jpt improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted
double concatenated file like it hasn't
created that file it had created the
file when we have written to it that you
forgot to create that file so charge APD
it modulates the existing code also
and moving on
now
in any
okay we'll open the concatenated
underscore data Dot xlsx
and inside this
okay we have the product line
so what we'll do is
we will change the
name of the electronic assessors to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to Lifestyle
now we'll automate this process
and we can do this automation all the
files also from January to December
so we'll do that only okay
now here
we will command s
okay now we'll command the chat Jeopardy
that using python
I trade
through
all the Excel files
in the
directory so we are asking him to
iterate to all the Excel files in the
directory and we will ask him to replace
electronic assessors
electronic accessories
see the spelling
accessories okay
yeah Electronics SSS with electronic
equipments
and
also ask him
equipments um
[Music]
okay I'll do equipment only
and
home and lifestyle we have chosen yeah
home and lifestyle
and
change it with only
lifestyle
okay so using python we are iterating
through all the Excel files and changing
these
that would be in each Excel file
so we have to be specific without
written language and now we'll save the
modified workbook in
um we'll create another folder and in
that we will save the files
okay
save the
modified
file
in the
out
put folder
and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create it
okay
then create one
hold on
and return
okay oh I don't know why I'm saving this
so I have written the command I will
press enter
so that chatubity can process it and
give us the
code for that
so it's showing us
sweating and that was showing what
you're showing us
uh you can use the OS Library tool the
Excel files and integrity the panel is
laminated to read in the files and make
the changes and I'm Gonna Save the
modified files okay here's an example of
how you could do this
now here
we imported OS pandas is PD and it has
written the code I will copy that
this code will activate through all the
Excel files in the current directory
replace electronic recesses with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the showing in
the output folder doesn't exist the
script will create it
you would also use replace function to
replace values in the column okay
and they will write it through all the
cells in each of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electronic equipment and women lifestyle
with lifestyle if the cell value is
equal to the respective string okay we
have copied a code
and now
we will create a file
and
name it as itrade.py
it paste the code here and run it for
you guys
the code has been executed successfully
now we'll see
open all the files not all but yeah let
me open some
that was the previous Electronics this
is
okay so it hasn't changed
in this
okay we will open another file
and see if we code the changes in that
or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it hasn't
done its job
so we'll move back to GPT
and use this code if it functions else
we will write back to the chair GPD
okay
just a second
okay we are using the replace
and find the next sentence
okay
so for that you have to report
OS
done
known underscore book
and for that
let me bought this
and run it
include these files
okay
now we'll see
if we quote our solution or not
no it's showing electronic accessories
and home and lifestyle
so
chat GPT doesn't
go to the code to change them
so we'll ask him another time and with a
different language this time
that's why I don't think it has created
the output folder
it has oh sorry
I'm really sorry what I have done is my
mistake
those were the original files
and we have the product line here
and we have electronic accessories here
and that should be equipments
okay uh we have electronic accessories
and lifestyle
let me see my command
okay I have asked them to
change Electronics with electronic
equipment and
My Lifestyle with lifestyle so let's
change only lifestyle
and see
okay
uh the E here is small
we'll update that
in the code
you can write this back to chat jpd also
but yeah
first
we'll do this
and what am i showing
notice executed successfully
okay
in the output folder we have the
December
accessories
that's in the capital E okay okay
so this code is giving us error
we'll see the last code and copy that
and
try to use this
and close the terminal and run it again
it has a rooted successfully now we will
see the file
and that has changes or not it has not
now we'll ask the chat GPD
what have you done brother
you're using python Android tools Excel
files in adapter and replace electronic
accessories with electronic equipment
and home and lifestyle with lifestyle
okay in each Excel files save the
modified modifiers.com
[Music]
okay
we will ask the same thing once again
to him
and with this electronic accessories oh
sorry
and save the modified file
now output folder and get a folder
window doesn't exist okay
okay
um
[Music]
you haven't seen once again
let's just close these files
and recruited successfully now we'll
open it
and now we can see that it has changed
to electronic equipment
electronic equipment
yeah now it has executed successfully
maybe there would be an error with us
while copying it as we have also created
the output folder but we forgot to see
in that folder maybe that could be the
error from our site
now we are done with the
changing of the column names
uh it's the cell names that was
electronic accessories to electron
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle
now we'll do the next automation
for that
first we'll open an Excel file
uh this was in the output folder
you can get back to our main directory
and open the file July
and here
here we'll build
filter the Excel file or gender
that is we'll select gender as female
and with the unique values in column
City
and will extract the data from
column A to q that would be the whole
data
and for each Unique city value we'll
create a new Excel file for each City
and that will contain data only for that
City and for females only
and after that we'll save this file in a
folder name setting so we'll give this
command to chat jpd
and here you can also specify the module
you want chat chip it to use for the
particular command
here we will be commanding our chat GPT
to use the pandas module and for that
we'll write the command
node command in the natural language
we'll give this command to the chat jbd
and for that we'll write using Python
and pandas
filter the
okay we will just pick a single Excel
file
or we can
pick the concatenated file
that is concatenated underscore data
filter the
concatenated
underscore data
Dot
Excel SX
Excel file
and that would be for gender
female
and by the
unique values in column City
we first will give the command
by the
unique values
in the column
City
and after that we want to extract the
data from column A to q that is the
whole sheet
extract the data
from the column
A2
q and for each Unique city value
for each unique
City
value
now we will extract the data and now
we'll create a new Excel file so for
that also we'll give the command to chat
jpd and we'll write
create a new Excel file
and that would be for each City
okay
so we will write
create a new
Excel file
or each
City
containing
data
only for
that
City
and for females
okay
and save this file in the
City folder
and if it's
not been there
GPT can create the folder for that also
okay
City folder and
naming the
each file with the city name okay
naming each file
after the
course
bonding
City
okay
now
if the
CT folder that is we have written the
small City
okay
if the city folder doesn't exist
then create it
before seeing the files
okay
now we have given this command to the
chat GPT and it has responded us with
you can use the pandas Library as we
already mentioned to use that to read in
the continuated underscore data.xlsx
file and filter the data for gender
female group the data by the unique
values in the city column and extract
the data from the specified columns for
each group and here is an example
so we have Port the code
we'll wait till chat jpd continues
and we can see that the chat GPT has
completed
and
we will copy this code
for sitting
[Music]
General female
data root Group by okay City
and you could also use the engine method
to filter the data frame for female
gender okay first
we'll see
this
and for
that we will create filter.py
and run the code
it has been executed successfully so now
you'll see that the city folder has been
created or not
I'm not able to see the city folder
okay it's been created
so you can see okay it's been created
man it's still empty
so we'll give time
okay and we quote an error it is
okay okay we will pass this error to
chat jpd first
and after that we'll see what's wrong
with this
on your so the error message you're
saying isn't getting that the column
name specified in the list
are not present in the data frame it's
likely that the actual column names in
the data frame are different than the
ones you specified in the list
okay you just see the list
that is concatenated data
go back
and see that is A2
okay it's still r
okay made a little mistake here
so we'll just
change our Command
yeah this is it
and
instead of Q now we'll write r and save
and submit now we'll see what it did
generate for us
I'm going to close this
foreign
great and extract the data from the
column eight wire for each Unique city
name and then create a new Excel file
for each City containing data only for
that City and for females files will be
saved in the city folder naming each
file after the corresponding setting
okay
done now we'll copy this code
and paste it here and see
whether this code works for us or not
so it's being executed successfully now
we have moved to the city okay it's
executing so we'll give time
to the code
and it do it so yeah it's been execute
successfully
okay so there were three cities that was
Mandalay
Pato and Yangon
and if I show you the data
and you could see
there's c three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the settings only the unique cities and
it has extracted the data for the gender
female
now we'll see those files
close this
and back
in the city folder
would see them and lay City
and the data is just for the females
so this automation works well with jet
gbt
now moving on we will do one more
automation
and that would be to use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode
so for that
I will just
get you aware of the payment modes in
our sheet and we'll do this automation
on the concatenated data sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the amount of payments that is
Ebola cash credit card
and these are repeating so we will use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment mode from column m
sorry and that is from this sheet only
and then we'll create a new sheet and
name it as
count.xlsx and write the count against
each payment method
so we will give this command to our chat
gbt
and ask him to write the code for our
automation
so we are writing use Python to identify
use Python to identify
what is the
count
of
each
payment method
from
column and the column was n from column
n and that was in
concatenated
underscore data dot xlsx sheet
and
create a new sheet
named
count Dot xlsx
and
write the count
against
each payment method
okay
now we have given this command to our
chat jpd and we'll see what it offers to
us you can use the pandas library today
okay that's the same value counts
function to get the count of each main
method okay and you can use the 2XL
method to the data frame to write the
count to a new sheet okay that's good
and he has imported the pandas library
and create the DF variable in which he
has read the concatenated
file and used counts function with the
payment method
and when we go to okay the column name
is payment
note payment method I think it would
generate
an error for us
so
it's python of each one method from
column
n
and we will specify
column M and that is named
payment
as it has used payment method here you
can see
that it has used the
column name s payment method
so we will specify this
we have to be very specific with our
commands
for these automations for simple tasks
you can use
simple language
you know complex sentences or you have
to mention every detail but for these
automations you have to use them
now our chat Jeopardy is working with
this and mostly he will deliver us with
the perfect code I hope so
okay uh
test right and the value count and it
has
exported
mode reset
you would also have function method and
use the size version
method okay
okay we'll see this
oh
and here
we will create a file
as count.py
and in this file we'll paste the code
delivered us by the chair GPT
we have
executed it
s being executed we'll wait for that
it's mean as you would successfully
so we have back to our folder
and we have to look for
well count file now yeah account file
okay
it just no it's talking about okay yeah
it's showing us the
mode of payment status evolit cash
credit card and the number of
usage
you know four four eight thousand three
yeah it's 12 000 that was the whole
entry of the account candidated
underscore data dot xlsx so we have done
with this Automation and now we'll do
one last automation
and first we'll
close all these files
okay and moving back to our chat GPT and
now we will do
will rename all the 12 Excel files that
was January February to December and we
will add the word
or car sales
just before the month name that would we
will just add the prefix before the
month name
and for that
we will give the command to the chat GPT
in the natural language
and here only we'll change it
in the mid directory only as we have the
copy of all these files
so for this we'll write the Quant use
python
rename
all the 12 Excel files
named
January
February
until December
okay
and that is present in my
directory
and what we have to do is we have to
add
uh the board
will add Car Sales okay
car sales
and
in front of
each
each file name
okay
so what it will do is Car Sales
underscore January Car Sales underscore
February and so on
so we'll wait for the chat GPD you can
use the OS library to iterate through
all the Excel files in indicted and then
use the restore training function okay
to rename the files here is an example
of how you could do this
go to S and we have the months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add car sales in front of each file name
and those files would be those only the
months
and good it's using the glow module
and you could also use the Chrome model
okay that's the second code
it's the easy one okay
but we'll go with OS first
and get back to R
ideally and name the file as rename Dot
py
and here we'll paste the code
and run it
it's been executed will move back yeah
you could see that car sales have been
added to all the files
and with that we have done with our
automations
and if you want you can also submit your
code to chatgpt and ask it to add
commands to your code so that it could
explain you what that line does or what
that function does it would explain very
tediously and
if you want you can also try chat gbd to
automate many office tasks
you can automate PowerPoint for that and
do many more tasks with chat jpd today
we are going to automate WhatsApp using
python Pi pivotkit library and with the
help of chatubity and before starting
I have a quiz question for you guys
and your question is how much did meta
that is formerly Facebook spend to
acquire WhatsApp in 2014. any options
are your first option is dollar 10
billion dollars second option is 19
million dollars third option is 20
billion dollars and the fourth option is
21 billion orders please answer in the
comment section below and we'll update
the correct answer in the pin comment
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
so moving on
now we will move to create a project
so first we will create a folder for a
project
and for that we will
create a folder in
python projects
and name it as
automate WhatsApp
using chat jbd
okay and inside this we'll open the
command prompt
and open our ID
that is we want to automate the WhatsApp
using Python and with the help of
Charity we won't write the code on our
own we will ask chargpt to automate it
we will create the file and name it as
main.ty
and now we'll move to chat jpt
and ask chat jbt
to write a code to send messages through
WhatsApp using Python and the pivot kit
Library
so we will give a command send message
through
WhatsApp using
Python and
private kit
let's see what
chat jpd response to us and we have also
created the automate WhatsApp using
python video
I will just Link in the I button you can
check that out
and we'll see what
chat GPT tells us okay
[Music]
country code message
minutes yeah it could work
and first you need to install the
pivotkit library
terminal or command prompt okay replace
Target phone number with the Target
phone number you want to send the
message to country code with the country
code of the Target phone number message
with the message you want to send r with
the RN 24r format and you want to send
message and minute with the minute you
want to send a message okay for example
yeah okay
all right so we'll copy this code
and
paste
in our ID
but before that
first you need to install the pivot kit
library and for that you can go to the
command prompt and
write the command
pip
space install space
pivot kit and press enter
it states that the requirement is
already satisfied as I've already
installed this module and you can
install it by writing the simple command
and we'll get it installed and if you
face any error installing it just
comment down
and would be very happy to resolve your
queries
Okay so
as chat GPT States we will just enter
the
things it won't promise so it's asking
the Target phone number and the country
code without plus sign
okay
so here we'll just
write all the things but as you can see
it has also given us an example
to see
and work on the code
so here
we'll just clear it
I will write the phone number to whom I
want to send the message
so it would be
and I would just blur this number so you
guys
won't be able to see okay
and here
will just
add the country code
and that is without plus sign
okay
so my country code is
you can search it that is I live in
India
and the message I want to send to Ms
hello
how are you
and now
we'll set the
RN minute so the current time is 15 14.
set
16. okay
we'll save this
and run it
so it says that the country code is
sync
so we'll just
copy the error and give it to chat jbd
as we are taking the help of chat
Jeopardy in this video
so he has given us the code so we'll
just provide the error to him let's see
but it states if it's not able
to resolve this then we will resolve it
as a country code
within the phone number you're trying to
send okay
yes and the country code is now I want
to send the message correctly you need
to make sure
okay
um one two three four five six seven
eight nine
you mentioned
right now provide that phone number is
this and the country code is nine one
okay
you need to make sure that country code
is refreshed to the phone number like
this
two three four five six seven eight nine
okay we don't have to make testing
yeah no
we will turn it again
okay it's a string only
so I will write the phone number again
yes
three
six
okay now we'll see
and
what I will do
I will write the country code here we'll
save this
and the time is 15 17 now so we'll just
22 15 18.
save this and run it
so our code has been executed
successfully that is in 20 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
so we just have to see that
we have enter the time as 15 18. use the
seconds
available for
the code to get executed yeah
it has opened the WhatsApp
it will take time as my WhatsApp has
loads of chats and contacts
here I have to scan it
don't think
it would be a as we have reached 15 18
you have scanned it
let's see if it will deliver the message
or not
else we have to change the time
so we just have to wait for 15 seconds
let's see
okay
just stop the terminal
and run it again
4 15 21 so we will
save this and run it again
so it states that in 85 seconds WhatsApp
will open and after 15 seconds message
will be delivered
so we'll get fast forwarded here
so we are still waiting
let's see I mean it will open the
WhatsApp
okay it states that the phone number
shared by URL is invalid
okay I'll just check the phone number
again
[Music]
okay I entered the wrong phone number
sorry guys
oh I will just update the time again
and it would be 15 22. we'll make it
fast we'll run this
okay let's say that the call time must
be greater than so we're at 15 23 7.
we will make the
time is 15 27.
save it and run it
okay it states that's in 40 seconds
WhatsApp will open and after 15 seconds
message will be delivered
it has opened the WhatsApp
and it has started the chat
okay it has
written the
and we have send it to hello how are you
that's good AI art and chat GPD can be
used to create unique and creative web
design by combining the power of
artificial intelligence and human input
with AI art you can generate visually
stunning Graphics patterns and images
while charging Beauty can be used to
generate text content and provide
suggestions for website layouts and
design element so hey everyone you are
already watching simply learn and today
we bring you this informative video on
chat Deputy for UI and ux before we
begin if these are the videos you like
to watch then hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon to get notified every
time we upload a new video without any
further delay to get started you can
experiment with different air tools to
generate graphics and use charge repeat
to write website copy create a Content
strategy and provide feedback on Design
Elements it's important to keep in mind
that while AI can help to generate ideas
and create stunning features I'm going
to show you exactly how you can generate
these yourself websites are going to be
built with air as well as tools like
chargpd in future so in this video I am
going to explain the whole process and
we are going to have it right the entire
Website Layout for us all the content
the hero section and feature section and
much more this means that we can build
the entire website from the ground up
without writing a single line of code
and this will be a pretty damn good
alright we will start with the mid
journey in Google's search we will write
a journey
this is an AI tool that allows you to
create the air that we are now seeing
all over the web to go to this you just
go to the midchairney.com and join the
beta it's easy to get started because
all you really have to do is join the
Discord when you do this it will open up
the Discord Community which you can
accept the terms and condition and start
creating your own AI Arts let's do this
now
here I have got the mid Journey server
and I'm going to head over to one of the
newcomer room here and and where
everyone is creating different types of
air the first thing we need to do is uh
to do a forward slash and type in an
imagine give us prompt
we can request the AI any type of art we
are after here I'm going to dive uh in a
beautiful website
for
shoe
then I'm going to pass in dash dash
V4 which means the version 4 of the mid
20 of air tool finally I'm going to pass
it in style stylize I'll do Dash
stylize it's basically how random we
want to be in uh it's between zero to
thousand and I'm just going to set it to
about 500 which is average I will do the
enter it will take a little bit of time
this will start working in the
background it's going to generate a low
Fidelity version of the website and the
design for this art and this low
Fidelity version will be iteratively
updated to be higher in resolution these
four examples then can be picked from
and then we can upscale them as well as
let's have a look at what kind of
results we get now one thing uh to
notice here is that we do get a bit of a
loading percentage bar and this is how
long it takes for the actual AI to
generate the image I usually takes
between one to two minutes but it will
essentially refresh and pink you once
it's complete so here is it is complete
and here are the four versions that we
got which are not too bad are not that
great either they are a bit uh yeah I
suppose it's looking funny in a way so
this is a way we can start being more
creative with our prompts so what I mean
that uh is by giving more context as to
what we want to do so here is a prompt
that we have created what I'm gonna do
is to pass it in the imagine once more
and I paste this prompt in this and I'm
going to give some more context I'm
going to pass it to the word UI
choose UI QX
UI ux website this basically means that
it's more or less focused on having good
UI and good at ux and being more like a
website rather than just a creative shoe
or a design and it's important to give
these context clues to the AI if you
want better outputs different types of
context clues you can provide is to find
a kind of style that you want uh for for
example
um how you want the design to look and
feel whether you want to to represent a
certain brand or much much more like
these are just simple examples but let's
take a look at the kind of results we
will get just from making these small
little changes to the design here here
you can already see a wait a minute look
it's a little bit more interesting we
have a bit of our sliders and what looks
more like a Nike shoes and also have
what looks like a menu at the top and
and I really like this design that we
have here on the bottom and here it is
because it does look very much like a
website that we have got a bit for a
hero section or a hero set section and
what's not so from here we can select
the version one uh so from here uh we
can select uh the version one two three
uh four to upscale and I'm going to
upscale version 3 where which is u3 and
this will give us a high resolution
version of this one particular design
that we again that we can start to take
uh to the market or even you can use to
build this again uh will take a little
bit of time it's going to process this
and uh to do and you can upscale in data
and let's run this in the background so
that you can see uh a wait a minute this
again will takes a little bit of time to
process it's going to process this and
do an unscale or upscale in beta and
let's run this in the background so that
you can guys see what's the look so
here's the final result and this is
looking uh pretty and we have got a nice
design here for a shoe we have got a bit
of a hero section and we also have what
looks uh like a two call to actions and
we got some option here too at the very
bottom and as well as at the top we have
got these colors and that essentially
are looking like these shoes colors
being used as a part of the website
design so not too shopy let's select uh
the another one let's see for
yeah uh but I think we can do a little
bit more
um in terms of customization the design
for this website and I'm going to show
you how you can do this I'm going to
copy over this uh prompt once and for
this prompt this time I'm going to pass
a couple of extra things so let me just
maximize this
we are going to type
um as I have uh pasted that URL over
here so I'm gonna pass and the context
clues of like uh
clues of Nike because Nike made
obviously website shows so also
uh so we'll write it here
Nike
not here
repeat and I also want it to be read
blue
green
and
or maybe yellow
and I suppose we want uh else running
person
would be interesting
sorry person
uh it would be interesting to see how
that gets designed uh and I think that
there should be enough let's actually
improve the styling here uh one minute
it's just styling
let's
let's have it 750 uh to make it a little
bit more creative and here are the
results I don't have a running person
but I do have a website that has
definitely started using the colors that
I recommended with Chinese air systems
to use so these website designs look way
more creative than we had previously
still we have this slider design this
website designs look way more creative
than we had previously we still have
this slider design here at the bottom
section where we can pick out different
shoes but even these shoes look damn
cool I can see that the Nike logo
on these and these are actually ones
that I would probably buy if I saw in
the Nike store but generally uh these
also are website because we have got the
menus here at the top of the right we
got the text so generally speaking uh
these are pretty interesting interesting
designs so now I have another option
here called version one two three four
what this does is actually allow you to
pick uh more Generations uh based on
actual image from these images or these
designs now from these design I actually
like the trail 3 and 4 I think it is
most I think
four because
uh it deals and red or it's a bit yellow
or blue so I'm going to select the
version
um four and that's gonna create uh four
more version based on the specific
version for us let's take a look at the
what those that we got and here we have
got our results
uh where we have more examples of that
all of these looks very similar I think
the only difference here is uh Blue Line
a red line it seems to be shift and
change as well as a hero section
and and you would normally have this
menu at the top right and something
these shoes here are a little bit
inverted but generally speaking this is
the kind of variations you can expect
now let's take a look at another way we
can generate Our Generations for website
now you can do is just jump into any
website and select any image so first we
will go to an app and website and you
can uh select any image that you would
like and I will actually go on here
and I'm going to pull in this image of
this shoe and but I do like the design
Aesthetics uh here we are going to here
and then we can copy the URL from here
but this time what I'm going to do is
type the Imagine
imagine
then I'm going to pass in the URL what
we have copy uh we will paste it here
again I'm going to write
we did it before we'll copy this
paste it over here
so what's going to happen here it's uh
it's going to have a look at this image
that we have defined in in terms of the
URL it's going to use this as a
reference point then it's uh going to
take a look at the prompt we have potent
which is the show prom
using the colors and it's going to try
to design
a website that has a similar Aesthetics
to that image which is really cool let's
see the result we get back looks like
that's ready let's take a look at this
so here you can see that the design is
Statics
uh wait a minute
static uh that is uh similar to the page
scene in this one
so this is more bubbly and colorful
image and now are represented very much
so in this design Aesthetics uh we have
these four elements here at the bottom
and if you have a look at the design
originally we had four elements here so
you can see that it's pulling in these
design Aesthetics to create a design
based on that and this is where you can
really start using the air art repeat
using the air tool to your own benefits
trying to combine different styles
customizing them and creating new and
independent and unique ones from there
so in this four I'm really like uh the
version of fourth one or the second one
is pretty so what I'm thinking of doing
is an upscale on this so we are going to
upscale uh V2 and we are going to wait
for that one minute is uh you start CPT
to write out the most of the content for
me and then I would I could take this to
a client to immediately start shading so
let's see the upscale version happen if
we take a closer look we will see that
it has all the main elements for the
website including a logo area a menu
area a nice hero image as well as a
title tagline Button as well the feature
section so what I'm going to do is to
save this image to my computer I'm going
to save it and then customize it a
little bit but before we do that uh we
are gonna head over to a GPD
here we're going to prepare the outline
for the website using some AI tools so
here I'm going to ask rgpd to give me
the product outline
for a website
or shoes
hero title
tagline call to action button and
section four features and details about
the shoe so let's see what charge
ability will comes back with
um it's pretty quick uh it's got a Title
Here call to action button features are
detail section and it's not really
telling me what these are these are
where we might need to be a bit more
specific as to what we wanted to do it's
given me uh it's giving me like broad
outline of the website on what it needs
so please I will write
please provide
then
for each one of these that I can copy
paste
trade
to the website
um hero title is here tagline call to
action buttons
features
okay
and the details
okay detailed specification is there
okay reviews and rating
okay
so I think I have got enough hairs to go
by to Simply copy paste in the website
so let's start beginning to design this
I have opened this design up in the
Photoshop and I'm going to actually just
crop it into the main element over here
and I really want to capture this
image and I will crop it and I will
clear out the rest and we can design
each aspects or each part of this design
bit by bit
I will save it over here
it's time to build our website so I'm
gonna head over to editor X
and I'm going to build this uh a website
in this I have login already and then I
will create to a new site and here I
will take an add to a web dashboard and
I'm going to start by copy copy paste
all the elements from chat GPD as well
as mid Journeys trade and the first
thing and I want to jump back into the
chat GPD here and copy over our hero
text so I will just take it first
and I'm going to tab add title and I'm
going to paste it over here
and then I'm also going to grab the
tagline but before I will make it sure
to keep it over here
but before that
I will first I will
put one image over here
I will change the image
as I have already uh downloaded the
image
let's
upload that image
will open it let's wait to get uploaded
yeah it's uploaded and now we will
update it
let's make it big in size
okay so we will
we will change the size but first I will
remove this I will change the size for
this I will make it little small
next I will add the icon for
uh
for the company of the shoes that we I
am going to make a website for I will
add this
and I will update it
make it small
and this will be the taskbar but
make the size uh small a bit
and we'll
insert one more picture
and it will be the logo of the company
that we are going to put over here
we will minimize it we can resize it
can keep
keep the low over here
in our next uh then I'm going also going
to grab the tagline over here so I'll
quickly
I'll pick this time
I will add the text
comes up over here
okay I make it
small in size
and we will
paste on
and finally Let's uh grab a call to
action which says shop
and create a button button for that
so so here we have all the workings of
what we uh at least what we would need
at least
so for for the content
let's resize this first
now we will add we need to add the image
itself so instead of just having a
browse to stock images or anything like
that we actually had our images either
done inside of the photoshops that we
have done before as from the mid Journey
as well as so I'm going to just drag
the image
and I'm going to change the image
and it should be here I've already
downloaded no I have to upload it I have
a collections of some
shoes uh let's see
and I will just install one I'll upload
this picture
it will take a bit of time let's wait
for a while
unwanted upload it we will
we will update it
let's keep it like this
or we can
so we change our content place from that
to make it a fix in a place
so here we can
change this also
a pretty well
okay
so basically have this text happening a
little bit more
okay thing here
we have seen how we can resize it from
this scroll bar
and
so now let's add one more uh picture
over here to make it look more better
let's take a picture from here
change the image
upload from
computer
damn it from
now
we will upload it again sorry
and we'll update it
let's resize it
let's turn it on
it's a make a taskbar for the top top
most of the screen we will have a home
page so we will write a text over here
that will be
I'm going to make it small a bit in size
we'll add another text
it it will show about us
it will show about us section so we'll
write it over here
a little small two
let's make same size
speak more small
allow let's make it more alarm
okay uh the next next session will be
services
and the last one is context one section
foreign
that is a start button like uh we are
keeping the start button over here so we
will we are keeping this here so let it
be here
so next uh what I'm going to do I'm
going to select
add a section and I'm going to just have
a blank section
um
here I'm gonna do first I will add a
picture first as a background
let's do it I will add one picture let's
see I have downloaded or not
yeah I will download it wait a minute
Let It Be upload
I will update it
that would be a hole for a whole page
so
let's add the pictures now
for another shoes
here's the picture
I'm going to reopen this
and put
this
okay I'll update it
to edit it
keep the pictures over here like
similarly we will upload three pictures
over here
after this let's keep it here
let's keep this here
we are going to add another title over
here
we need to believe
foreign
we will change the font for this
let's make this
yeah after this I'll we will start
editing the features of the shoes let's
go to chat TVD
let's take this first
paragraph
and make it small
we make it port
we will add another paragraph over here
similarly we will make it for this also
and last we will add
a contact us
plus we will add a contact a section
over here again
so this is the final output
of chat GPD or how we use charge GPT and
air for our UI and ux design to create a
website or a web page or the land page
for the shows
charge GPT has various application in
various domains in this video we are
going to see the application of chat gbt
in the SEO domain also we are going to
discuss how chat GPT will play an
important role in search engine
optimization so here is a question for
you chat GPT is based on which of the
following GPT models created by open AI
Option 1 chat gpt1 option 2 chat gbd2
option 3 chat GPT 3 and option for none
of the above let us know your answer in
the comment section below and if your
answer is correct you will get a hard
from simpler as we discussed earlier
chat jpt is the application of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning if you are looking to get
certified into Ai and machine learning
then here at simply learn we have a
certification course for you difficult
intelligence is a growing technology and
the most trending jobs these days if you
are looking to get certified have a look
at artificial intelligence Masters
program by simply learning the course
covers all the details with the industry
projects of artificial intelligence if
you see there are number of tools
covered in this certification like numpy
pandas Side by spark Keras tensorflow
are programming python Scala Etc this
artificial intelligence course is in
conjunction with the IBM so what are you
waiting for have your own certification
and get a good salary hike a good career
with artificial intelligence you can
check the link in the description box
below so before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply land we know that SEO rankings
depends on various factors like on-page
optimization of page optimization and
more while using chat gbd we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
SEO ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chatgpt
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog
so before that let's choose what kind of
blog we want to create I really love
traveling so let's try to create a
travel blog so for the travel blog we'll
find some good keywords
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
suggest me good keywords to create a
blog
on which bank
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are few places like
Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
foreign
recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank foreign
places
to visit
in
Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat gbt
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect us to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh chat jpt provides you the
facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to save a number of words like
if this Blog has two thousand or five
thousand words you can just ask chat GPT
to reduce it to 2000 or 1000 words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords
to increase its reach
foreign
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
as a good title helps the user to click
on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
thank you
add the best
suitable title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
top 10 places to visit in Japan
Within
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title in the blog
to mice
blog
the word
top 10 places to visit and
okay so it is showing their relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blob using
all these factors
foreign
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
add headings H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for uh getting your page
rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me if you would
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these uh blog pages in
your website or if you have created any
of these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 places to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this blog
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
the amount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
title and
Alt
tag
for
mount
Z image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
qg
Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
choose
the amount
CLG image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
Mount Fuji
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us a suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of UNS and unsplash
pixels or Shadow stock to download the
image so we can really navigate to these
websites and download some of the
required image
for our blog
so we we have a completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
or your blog page
suggest me
suggest
video ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
above idea is best match for my blog
let's try to extract anyone from the
above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization ideas
optimizations
for
amount
using video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey uh thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
suggest me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags for
the
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites social media platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black background
I repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks whatever blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
yes the
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
top 10
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so
uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate these kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO
optimized
URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four sharing
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting
on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
backing for their web and this is again
going in symbiotic way like if they are
asking for a battling for from your blog
you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above
log so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that search engines are really in
love with the unique content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to chargeably is
not able to identify the duplicate
content however it is suggesting us some
of the tools like copyscape or sideliner
to understand if the content we are
creating for our blog is duplicate or
not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content
unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create a unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is 404 Pages four not four pages
are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
thank you
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the chat GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of our
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
if you are really interested to
create one of your chat gpts or create
some of these type of AI models which
will definitely reduce the manual work
then you really need to have the
knowledge of a good knowledge of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning that GPD is truly a fascinating
technology changing how we interact with
language it's the result of years of
research and development by open AI who
have trained the model on a massive
amount of Text data to create a machine
that can easily understand and generate
human-like text imagine you are a
digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that charge gbt uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chatgpt will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how change EPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every feed be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of ciajpt and your options
are option A Allen mask and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and satyana data
option C
[Music]
drop your answer in the comment section
below but before we begin let me ask you
if you are aiming to get certified in
digital marketing and want to build a
career in digital marketing then Unleash
Your digital marketing potential with
simply learn get ahead of the
competition and upskill with simply
learns IMT ghaziabad digital marketing
program learn from industry experts gain
hands-on experience with real world
projects and master inbound and outbound
marketing strategies to drive business
growth
join our community of successful
Learners today and become a digital
marketing Pro in no time to learn more
about this digital marketing course
check the link in the description box
below
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of chat jpt in digital
marketing its main USB is smart human
sounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first on our agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
[Music]
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learn digital marketing Master's course
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
[Music]
and hola it gave us a long version of
that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters we
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email newsletters
thank you
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter new query what is
Facebook
thank you
[Music]
it has given us a journal overview of
Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase it
more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well jgpt can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing course
site
[Music]
thank you
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
foreign
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
[Music]
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
thank you
[Music]
here we have an article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to SEO optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
here we have fully SEO optimized article
with meta title and meta description
where the SEO optimized URL chat GPT can
also be used to train your customer
service chatbots but we can discuss the
process in some other video chat jbt is
well versed with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the queries write a
product marketing campaign Force
Implement digital marketing courses
foreign
Ty has done it again this campaign looks
interesting and it will be able to
generate more leads for simple lens
courses chat jbd can also be used to
write scripts for YouTube videos let's
give it a query as write a script for
five minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
foreign
[Music]
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
foreign
and I wrote a customer collaboration
email that looks professional plus easy
to read and understand I hope this video
helped you understand more about chatgpt
uses in digital marketing and if you are
a digital marketer or a content creator
this will help you out in increasing
your productivity 10 volts if you like
this video and want more such videos
then let us know in the comment section
below and also hit the like button and
share it with your peers until next time
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here